based on what you've learned so far
what's your advice to younger actors who
are following in your footsteps maybe
they came from a little pond and now
they're coming to LA and they realize
there could be stereotypes maybe there's
not but they're up against a big pool of
people being here in LA I feel like at
this point in my life 25 years old like
you have to do it now like you have to
pursue it like if you don't then you're
going to weigh in the uniform the same
tripod will do where they get
comfortable in their jobs and they you
know forget about your passion if you're
if arts if the arts are your passion you
need to pursue it you know if it doesn't
work then doesn't work at least you know
that you gave it a shot I mean coming
here you have to like become fooling
yourself you have to be coming you're
assaulting your abilities and I go to
any every casting that you feel that you
fit and hope that someone likes you and
if they don't like you maybe they can
suggest you to someone else that like
you like I've been to only like a few
castings here so far but in those kind
of things I've networked with people and
I played at other auditions or I've been
to like I think oh I like a party and
I've landed another audition because you
have to just met work use this industry
especially in LA is so much about
networking I read an article about the
power of a referral like I wouldn't have
known about that audition if I didn't
talk to that guy at that party you know
anything so it was like getting to know
people and just following your dreams
like I the trip here was I can get into
the entire trip here was just like a
nightmare just like the process of
getting here and like you know here
getting to LA and trying to find a place
and like trying to find an agent it's
just such a hard battle but I know that
when I'm done I'm going to have a story
and I'm we really proud
I'm going to be very happy that I did it
so I say go for it when he comes to an
MFA in acting in whatever field because
I president MFA in acting for film where
all my five years of college were in
theater and before that all my training
was in theater in classical theatre my
advice would be to every young girl or
every woman that wants to go for an MFA
get an education before that in your
field I can't tell you how many women
will walk into an MFA acting program and
come from a completely different
background from a completely different
occasion that hurt women more than
somebody tell them get breast implants
or lose weight or anything that hurt
women more because they walked into a
world they had no shields for they had
no protection they walked into a world
that said oh now you have to stand with
all your emotions make it on stage
good luck with that and you asked me one
when I came from the corporate world
that came from being a mother that came
from chemistry my kidding me women that
there used to be Hedy all of a sudden
you're asking them to put their emotions
out on stage that hurt them more than
somebody telling them get breast
implants or lose weight why because
somebody will tell them that in the
actual outside world - not just in the
theatre Hollywood world they had men
tell them things like that and they'll
brush them off in this industry women we
somehow learn to walk past those things
even if that split of a second they will
hurt we learned to walk past them but if
you're trying to make a career out of
being emotionally raw on stage or in
front of the camera and you have no
train
behind that that will scar you for life
and I've seen I've seen classmates of
mine get out of grad school and never -
never pursue his industry never even
signed up they had that package in their
hands they worked out that dropped it in
the trash and move on in life because
they weren't prepared they didn't have
the five years of training that I had
and I worked in being like I don't know
walk out of that and I'm gonna be ready
to work this is just another stage in my
career it's not my career does that make
sense for them was the end of the road
grad school was the end of the road I
was sad and so they all the money they
paid student loans everything now it's
just the student loan and I'm speaking
for specific people that I know yeah I
was the end of the road for them some
moved on to become make parties some
moved on to nothing at all summers don't
to just have a families and kids and not
pursuing this business ever again cuz
grad school was a scoring experience it
was hard it's not just going class every
day like any other school that you have
to write 10 pages papers you're on stage
in front of the camera 24/7 literally
every day you have to be makeup and
camera ready and you have that casting
director professor behind the camera
saying you're not gonna get the leading
lady because you're fat in the real
world but here yeah sure here the waiter
from me comes out to a mind willing to
live with the rest of my life for people
they care that black girls like that or
deny it and do I connect with that that
character that's what it comes down to
because honestly money comes and goes it
does but it's my happiness and how do I
feel about myself that's more important
to me what can you really do that's not
like that if you're if you're if you
have a regular job that's fun it's
interesting but you'll never experience
the same thing you experience when
you're in a creative environment when
you're putting together a play or
putting together a documentary or act
in a movie you don't get that feeling
and now and that's why people who are in
our actors they live in their 80s and
90s because they're having so much fun
you know they're open that they're
opening themselves to everything you
know you're putting your put in
situations that you've never been in
before
and it's it's like a light comes on when
you get it when you know you nailed it
you know it's great it's just it's just
I can't explain it is if you're talking
to someone who does plays or whatever
you can really they understand what what
you're talking about if you do a play
when you leave you're so jacked up I
mean you're like in another world it's
like you're so high you know but you
can't let someone experience it's that
they can't really know what it feels
like
she said mark you're a bit lazy and a
little bit afraid bit lazy and a little
bit afraid the flip side of the coin and
I'm going to go segue many years after
the fact I had the pleasure of working
in Steven Spielberg's hook as a pirate
that was 1991 a lot of years
chronological years but he interviewed
all the Pirates himself one on one I
submitted to drama-logue got called in I
was non-union at the time background I
did some voices and accents in he just
looked at me saying you got a lot of
guts so for the flip side got a lot of
guts and throughout the years Karen I
but attempted to me to work out of that
laziness out of that laziness and that
and that fear but and and have a life as
well work regular jobs and so on and so
on but I can always but I say that to
say there's always room to to even work
more out of the laziness and the being
afraid the fear of success even in
regular life outside of acting just wish
that people could get along that people
could see each other just past the skin
because if we all filled our skin off we
would just be the same you couldn't tell
at all who we were I think if people in
the case in point with Saturday Night
Live for instance when they were not
forced but just compelled to bring on
African Americans and just they still
need to bring on Latina actors and stuff
that that is a great example of how the
show was enriched because of these
different perspectives even the show
orange is the new black look at all
those beautiful women and they're all
different and people love that show
I think if people would realize the
executives maybe the powers-that-be
that these kind of things work and then
there's you don't see the shade of the
skin it's just different characters I
think that's what we need to do and I
think it would be successful money-wise
oddly enough and also beautifully
Isabelle right I remember this history
course in in college and the history
teacher first day of class came out and
said all right I want all of you to pull
out a piece of paper and pencil and and
write the name of your hero we're going
to spend the next you know 12 weeks
writing a story a history story
so before we start decide on you who
your hero is and I'll be right back and
so the professor leaves the classroom
and everyone's got the pen and pencil
and paper and they're jotting a name
down you know and he comes back and the
class was about 56 57 kids you know and
the teacher comes back and and and
collects all the paper and he's going
through it and out of the 50s I remember
out of the 56 57 kids he only saw four
female names right so even the women in
the room were writing men as their
heroes and so he only saw like for three
or four female names and out of all of
them there was maybe like one or two
whose names were you know
ethnic the rest of them were like you
know Harrison Ford or you know Panama
Jack or you know something kind of like
iconic you know and Bruce Wayne you know
or whatever you know and so I think that
has a lot to do with the way we grow up
we grow up we're watching Clark Kent
we're listening to Bruce Wayne and Peter
Parker and these are really kind of like
apple pie American names for heroes you
know and and they're men you know and
they're square-jawed and they're kind of
like tough and they're not and so that
comes into how we grow up and when we
get into a position of reimagining our
stories we basically regurgitate what
we've eaten all these years without
thinking about it you know and even as a
minority writer when I've written I've
had to really mindfully say well does it
have to be a guy does it have to be
white you know does it even have to be
Asian you know so I think even before we
get into the casting room about your
question sometimes it has to do with
from the writer you know how you kind of
make the source material if you make it
kind of really interesting it almost
gives everyone else permission to make
it more interesting if someone insults
me and they're not apologetic if they're
having a bad day obviously some people
have bad days and you have to figure out
how to communicate with that person but
if someone is insulting you and someone
is treating you being abrasive with you
and you say listen you know can we talk
you know are you having a bad day you
know I just feel I don't know if he
maybe you're having a bad day and you're
not really focused today that you're
being aggressive towards me
am I am i is there a problem between us
and trying to try and figure out a way
to figure it out because we're humans we
all do the same things we just do it
differently so I want to find out how
can we work together and if we can't
obviously
you know you just can't work with that
person but if you take that time out to
try and resolve it nine times out of ten
you will be able to resolve it one
you're there for a reason they have a
project they want to complete it and if
you say well I don't wanna be in this
project that's a problem so they want
you to stay there I mean they want you
to work with you so but most of the time
I don't have that kind of problem
I feel that you know I can communicate
well with people and I don't really I
don't really feel that that's gone to
end everything but obviously if it's
just so unbelievably terrible and you
can't resolve it there's no way you can
make turning a negative into a positive
you know it's obviously you just can't
you can't work with that person in the
beginning it was more like wow maybe I'm
very I'm too aggressive for him too
passionate mmmm - but see that's the way
I am that's the way I was brought up -
that's that with that that's that to me
that's who I am and so instead of
diminishing that instead of you know
kind of you know putting yourself in a
you know kind of like a in the fetal
position you know and say you know I'm
not gonna do that you know go in and do
that tackle that you know but I I tell
myself you embrace that take that in and
do the best that you can you know with
that particularly
I guess by by putting myself out there
which is a very vulnerable place to be
in but I do think that if you if you
have a dream when you pursue it and
you're 100% committed to that dream I
think you can manage anything and that's
the hope I have right now is just to get
out there to be seen to take my acting
classes to get to know people to do as
much work as I can and then
you know maybe someday I write my own
things so I can give myself the roles I
know I can play and then through that
kind of you know spread out and you know
that people know that I'm more than what
I seem to be you have to stay true to
yourself you know know who you are you
know no one can tell you who you are no
manager no agent no huge Hollywood
production you have to honestly know who
you are as a person and if you know what
you are as a person you're going to just
Excel and go the furthest other far you
know you just stay focused do what you
have to do but once again the main part
to the success is know who you are stand
true to it and if you don't fall and
break yourself you're going to exhale
you're going to go far you're going to
do great things in life and no one will
be able to stop you because you know in
your mind you know your heart I can do
this you know it's not going to be easy
you know but anything you know worth
fighting for it's totally worth that you
know my grandmother tells me that all
the time you know easy come easy go but
those things that you work your ass off
for and you go hard for sure you will
see some type of just vital just
improvement somewhere down the line and
you you know take on challenges that you
never thought you can take on but once
again you know who you are so you know
you can take on those challenges I would
say start with your history that's what
I would say because um if you know
specifically when it comes to
african-americans because often times
people tend to erase that really big
chunk of American history called
slavery and then the Jim Crow era and
then the silver right you know all of
that so I think knowing your history um
would really really anchor you because
we're resilient and so often we had to
create our own reality because of the
levels of oppression and boot
tea just which we're saying now you know
history is sadly repeating itself in
some ways things have gotten so things
have gotten better in some ways and it's
gotten worse in some ways and I would
think finding um artists outside of
Hollywood who inspire you it could be a
teacher it could be someone in your
family it could be someone on Broadway
but I think sometimes with the glitz and
glamour of Hollywood we forget that
these are real people and they're like
these light bulb moments like oh my god
you know so I think history um
definitely working like training like
knowing your craft be Richards
there's a book Lisa gay Hamilton I don't
know if you're familiar with a black
woman speak I think every every person
on this planet every actress not only
african-american actresses but
especially african-american actresses
should see that film because I watched
it and I cried like a baby
because I said oh goodness you can
survive and you can thrive even without
being a household name you can create
these wonderful opportunities for you
for yourself and I was looking at
someone like B I'm thinking wow um so I
mean there's no one answer but I think
that's what has helped me anger me
knowing who I am not apologizing for
myself self love because a lot of people
are attracted to the entertainment
industry a lot of broken people are that
instant gratification you want to be
famous you want to prove something to
your family members who said you will
never make it you know there are all
these reasons why people flock to a city
like this and and you
working everywhere um but specifically
cities like this and I and I would say
if you don't know who you are learn who
you are because something I told my
students I don't want you to just be the
most amazing actress or actor I want you
to be an amazing human being because
when the lights fade and there is no
applause you have to be okay with who
you are you have to be okay with the
choices you made and that does not mean
that I don't have moments of doubt that
does not mean that I don't have moments
of fear that does not mean that I don't
feel some type of way when I see other
actors getting roles that I turn down
and you know possibly making more money
than me um but I'm clear about my
mission and when you're clear about your
mission and when you know that this is
your true calling nothing can stop you
not a racist
casting post not a misogynistic
filmmaker who wants to put you in a box
when you're on set not a PA who comes up
to you talking about girlfriend you know
the stereotypes it's a good journey you
know
and that's why I'm excited to do this
because even saying this like I'm saying
it to you all but I'm saying it to
myself as well to keep to keep pressing
forward but I do know it to be true that
you can thrive if you want to and part
of that is not being so desperate
there's a level of like hunger you need
you know to make you you know it pushes
you but that desperation where you want
to do every single thing you have
choices and it's powerful and I feel
empowered because I activate my power to
say no to always do always doing no but
I try very hard to UM
not say yes to things that don't feel
well even if it pays well and for that
reason I feel like I'm in my own lane I
do I feel like I'm in my own lane and
I'm grateful so that's it